nvidia really has no choice but to
release the gtx 1180
this year welcome to horace hobbies so
as you guys already know there was a
huge mining boom at the end of last year
and the beginning of this year and this
led to really high sales and revenue for
nvidia and as a result their stock
market price increased tremendously
however over the last couple of months
the GPU mining demand has almost
completely died out because of the
consistently increasing difficulty to
mine cryptocurrencies
the consistently decreasing price of
cryptocurrency across the board and the
introduction of a six for very popular
crypto currencies like etherium overall
since the cryptocurrency mining demand
died off Nvidia sales and revenue have
been a lot lower because of the lack of
GPU miners buying their GPUs as a result
invidious stock prices have seen some
huge hits recently for example on June
20th 2018 Nvidia stock was 262 dollars
and 31 cents but just five days later it
dropped all the way to two hundred and
thirty nine dollars and twelve cents
that's almost a 10% loss in just five
days so obviously that's not good and
once this court has sales revenue are
revealed in via stock prices will most
likely plummet unless Nvidia does
something about it so the clear solution
for Nvidia for this issue would be to
launch the 1100 series because the 1100
series would bring in a lot more sales
and revenue for Nvidia and this would
hopefully prevent the downfall for video
or at least soften the plummet and the
best option for Nvidia would be to
release the gtx 1100 series during the
third quarter so that they can maximize
off the 1100 sales during the holiday
season of this year the conversion rate
is a lot higher during the holiday
season with online sales having a
conversion rate of a whopping 75% so I
really doubt Nvidia would want to skip
out on all these sales and launch the
in 2019 especially considering the
situation that they are in right now
also the 10 series cars are doing bad
like really bad gigabyte just published
their revenue and sales for the last
quarter and their GPU division revenue
is down by a whopping 6 million dollars
and that is a round of 58% decrease from
the first quarter of this year so it
clearly is a huge downfall on top of
this a Taiwanese company which could be
gigabyte supposedly sent back 300,000
GPUs backed Nvidia simply because they
had way too much to sell as it is clear
with the miners out of the picture no
one is really relating to buy the 10
series especially for the high prices
that they're being offered for right now
and with the high anticipation for the
1100 series thus NBA's sales are down
they have a huge inventory problem and
if it media doesn't do something about
this really quickly Nvidia and they're
adding board partners are going to take
huge hits in their stock value we have
been hearing about a rumor that suggests
that in July Nvidia 10 series cards will
have a 20% price drop and this is
probably why envía has abundant stock of
the 10 series so they need to sell all
that as soon as possible so that they
can launch the 1100 series soon and
catch all the boosted sales of the
holiday season if Nvidia doesn't release
the 11 series soon that an invidious
stock is definitely going to take a huge
hit even if the 10 series cards are
offered for much more reasonable prices
because the sales during the GPU mining
boom were so high that it is not
possible to achieve such high numbers
with natural sales and as a result in
video would have to offer huge discounts
on their 10 series and launched the 1100
series to at least achieve numbers that
are relatively close to that so I
strongly believe that Nvidia will launch
the 1100 series before the end of 2018
especially considering that they are
planning to go over the details of the
1100 series at the hot chips conference
in August and I doubt they're going to
wait over four months after that for
least 1100 series overall the GPU mining
boom led to high sales and revenue for
Nvidia for a lot months but once that
craze died out in media stocks plummeted
because of the decreased sales and
revenue on top of this tendon series
card sales aren't doing well and they
have a lot of excess inventory as well
so they have to offer really good
discounts in order to be able to get rid
of all these GPUs also they have to
launch the 1100 series soon if they want
to catch the holiday sales of this year
and prevent their stock from going down
too much thus it would be an invidious
best interest to launch the 10 series
before the end of this year in order to
prevent their stock prices from going
down and especially concerned that has
been over two years since the last
generation of GPUs launched but that's
just what I think what do you guys think
when do you guys think the GTX in 1180
is going to come out is he going to come
out this year or next year make sure to
comment down below what you guys think
because I do read all my comments I'm
curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like this video then make sure
drop a like and hit that subscribe
button if you guys like to see more
videos just like this one but until next
time bye
[Music]